does someone want to tell me what the
hell is going on with batman does
anybody want to tell me
what exactly is going on with the batman
so many crazy news everywhere new
reports
morning noon and night everyone's
getting their facts wrong
it's embarrassing what's happening out
there the hell's going on with you
scoopers
come on sources get it together get it
together sources get your details and
alignment i don't know where to get
excited i don't know where to be like
nah that's stupid
just tell me all possibility is exciting
race higher spectrum of possibility
let's break this [ __ ] down
so yesterday i saw this on twitter
everyone was running on this like crazy
uproar about michael keaton
taking over for ben affleck in the dc eu
that's that was the story that was going
around and i wanted to do a video on it
because i like talking about things i
just don't believe
i find it so silly but then my mind went
i bet this is going to be clarified in
like a couple of days
and it was like hours later he got
clarified
hours here's what happened in case you
guys are out of the loop
if you don't have twitter i have some
notes in front of me new york times they
posted this interview and article with
the head of dc
films walter hamada aka ray fisher's
best friend oh absolutely
someone asked a question to uh the
person who conducted this interview
uh named brooke barnes because in the
article they were talking about how
there might be two different film sagas
involving batman played by two different
actors right
i'm under the impression we got three
actors right now so already i was like
what
we gotta get more so nestor sign on
twitter was the lucky dog who started
all this
said hi brooke barnes based on your
hamada piece some have interpreted that
wb is doing two franchises starring
batman
one with pattison one with a new actor
is that correct
or were you referring to keaton as the
second batman being part of a non-batman
centric saga
thank you brooke barnes then said keaton
boom
the internet went ablaze it was bananas
okay every single trending hashtag of my
algorithm had something to do
with this because people were going oh
my god what the hell you're doing ben
affleck wrong
you know and then i was like okay maybe
that's why ben affleck looked the way he
did on new year's day
you guys see that photo i don't know
whether to be concerned or find that
hilarious you leave me
your thoughts down below and then rumors
started going about like okay does this
mean he'll be like the mentor to batgirl
will this be uh this is batman beyond
that they're worried about i finally
doing the batman beyond
batman beyond just got available on hbo
max oh my god it's all tying it's all
making sense i'm wait a minute no but
i'm mad i don't know what to do
and then brick barnes came out come on
brooke barnes you know how social media
is dude
you're you're an interviewer you got a
one-word answer to a multi-faceted
question you had to know that you were
going to cause a bunch of you
work for the new york times
communication is
key in your business man he said been
offline
moving apartments and returned to see it
as michael keating craziness
i was referring to the one film that
keaton has been announced as being in
not a set of his own batman films if i
had info on him beyond the flash i would
have
obviously put it in my article so then
bam
story shut down people who were mad or
no longer mad people who were excited
are no longer excited
on the span of a few hours here's the
conclusion though right
if i'm not mistaken we're supposed to
get robert pattinson
who will be batman in the matt reeves
films right then we're supposed to get
batman's ben affleck
and the snyder verse on hbo max and then
michael keaton might be using some dc
films maybe batgirl possibly some other
hbo max projects because they're doing
this
super multi-verse thing with live-action
films to confuse general audiences
but real fans will know what the hell's
going on
that's how you know they're real that's
how you do it guys that's how you do it
i'm excited for all personally on a
personal note i'm excited for all three
versions i really am i just find it
hilarious how
how bat [ __ ] how bad [ __ ] everything
went yesterday yeah michael keaton i'm
excited about
ben affleck i'm excited for him to
continue on
especially under the direction of snyder
or working along with slander
and of course i mean come on robert pads
is batman that's the best trailer last
year
off of the 10 trailers we got last year
it was the best one that we got they're
also saying
that on hbo max one of the reported
scoops that's happening
is att is trying to get together some
type of trinity film possibly a world's
finest movie
where you get superman in there batman
and
wonder woman but they don't know yet if
they want to court ben affleck's batman
for
it or if they want to court robert
pattinson's batman for it
it's all depending on whatever the
successes of the snyder cut versus the
success of the batman and personally
i think it would be super duper cool to
get a trinity film
like just focused on the three of them
but then i'm like i don't want to see
that on the big screen
yeah and i mean i find it funny that
they would even be in this position of
going well which batman do we want to
include because i feel like it would
just make everything all the more
strange fragmented and confusing if they
threw robert pattinson in with already
established henry cavill and already
established gal gadot
right right so i don't know if that
makes really any sense
but uh yeah the keaton stuff is funny to
me because of just how quickly people
will
just like take that football and go with
it because
like from the second they started
announcing his involvement it never
really seemed like he would be in a
position to
lead a new franchise like you know he's
not an
old man but he's older now yeah as many
you know cool takes on old man batman as
there are it just seems like a very
clear instance of the internet getting
way ahead of itself but i would still
really
love to see a michael keaton batman
beyond movie
i'd be a hundred percent down for that
100 down you get michael keaton
and terry mcginnis can be played by finn
wolfhard yeah
definitely yeah or or millie bobby brown
whichever one i'm cool with
or gayden matarazzo
deep cuts here stranger things kids yeah
but everyone only knows finn wolfhard
and millie bobby brown
and there's gonna be like five people
who are like i know who john's talking
to yeah and then there are gonna be
three more people who are like what
about the guy who plays lucas
i gotta go look his name yeah something
like that
look guys look batman i'm very excited
for what we got in store i just thought
this news was really funny
and i wanted to come here to clarify
everything for you
in the most efficient manner of all the
progress of what we really know
is being speculated on talked about
reported on
bullshitted on whatever oh you should
have done that
i'm i'm here for you the one word tweet
would have done it i'm here for you like
we should have just done a one-word
tweet
pedro pascal was barely in the
mandalorian season two
i was right guys why don't you do
yourselves a favor
subscribe to tyrone magnus's channel hit
the like button on grace randolph's
video
click the notification bell for 3c
films and while you're at it click here
to get stuck manized
last but not least
i want to shout out my homeboy andrew
hayes
andrew my buddy you got a lot geared up
this year
for where you can go with your future
for what you can get off the ground for
the creative pursuits some personal
pursuits
a whole bunch of things 2020 was rough
on a lot of us
so i want to wish you a happy new year
and i want to tell you
you're going to kick a lot of ass in
2021 you're going to be kicking
so much ass left and right women
or as you call them [ __ ] because
you're sexist are gonna
just be flocking to you all right like
flies on [ __ ]
you're the [ __ ] they're the flies not my
words your words
you call them flies i call them females
you call them
[ __ ] i say whoa andrew
not while you're on camera dude
you be safe out there patreon day shout
out complete happy 2021 to you andrew
hayes